[Music]
ruining everyone's lives you're ruining
my life this guy is ruining my life
but oh [ __ ] yes sight this guy's so [ __ ]
sorry I'm not you playing Baron as I'm
being toxic
remembering your won't go away from a
limo championship that hit too close to
home
hold that hold that this is what feels
like to be a winner
scrub killer talks a lot of [ __ ] but
he's proven time and time again that he
can back it up yo middle yeah but can
you Bethany whether he's dumped stirring
pros in 1v1 matches or scoring insane
last-second goals scrub killin never
lets what he's best known for [ __ ]
dumbass skin a gum I [ __ ] love a mess
with his gameplay
[Applause]
grubbé killer was already the hottest
free agent in rocket league when he was
just 15 while he was definitely fun to
watch his talent is what made him a
rocket League odd before he was even old
enough to play in they are LCS and he's
just getting started
wait no way look at those dollies right
now look at that scrub killer first
started playing video games with his dad
when he was about four years old but
after a few years he found one game that
stood out to him more than anything else
one game he was better at than almost
anyone he played against supersonic
acrobatic rocket powered battle cars
they say that right
[Music]
despite being just six years old when he
first picked up the game turns out scrub
had a natural talent for it I mean I
love people like call me uh prodigy and
stuff like I think when I started
playing really got one like the first
thing 28 games or something but I don't
think I'm necessarily gifted you know I
think I got to work as hard as everyone
else but supersonic acrobatic rocket
powered battle cars was only a pit-stop
on Scrubs journey
I think Mowgli's game for me because
first off is a mixture of like football
and cars another thing as well as disco
sealer
it's really really high I've got like
over $7,000 in raqqa leak and I feel
like I could still be way better scrub
killer was good at rocket League too but
he was too young to play in real
tournaments so he made a name for
himself
beating pros in 1v1 matches so scrub
going for the 360 no-scope JSOC I keep
about scrub does love to ashame his
opponents by just asserting dominance by
stopping the ball on the goal line
now say you start dominates the
disrespect by scrub there you have a
scrub superior challenging in the
midfield superior kickoffs able to take
that machine you of four games to three
in fact scrub was so good that people
thought he was a pro smurfing on amateur
didn't even blame most women he didn't
believe that it was a which which
persons shot you would be like faking
the year 12 he just wouldn't buy it but
defeating chrono V one of the most
popular rocket League players in the
world in a 1v1 is what made scrubber
realized that he was right I bet early
no one I wanted to start playing
professionally like a lot people ask
that like when did you become a pro it's
not like you just become an overnight
it's kind of like a school transition
but when I beat Kenobi in a 1v1 and then
go was like December of 2015 that really
like got me out there and after that I
really started playing in tournaments
and the house says when I really became
too but again even though he felt ready
scrubbed killer was still too young to
play in the our LCS when it was
announced so instead he made his name by
streaming his matches and quickly
developed a legion of followers
thanks in part to his over-the-top
on-air antics the devil look I'm going
for the devil double commit doc oh my
god next
no no I'm done I'm out you don't rage
aside though scrub remain focused on his
goal of one day playing in the our LCS I
wasn't until more recently when Rockley
came at the start taking a really
serious just watching other people that
like you know it just as good as you
when everything or you know do well and
they get try to get travel but you know
I just caught I just buddy did my time I
knew one day it could be me the second
the scrub killer turned 15 he
immediately became the hottest free
agent on the rocket league market and
was quickly picked up by run out
vitality just in time for season 6 of
the our LCS unfortunately with all that
pressure on the team and trust issues
between teammates vitality failed to
qualify for the World Championship that
year that shot off the backboard at
double digits in a major upset they take
out vitality what was supposed to be a
coronation for the future king of rocket
league quickly turned into a disaster it
was supposed to be the year scrub kill
the last season like there's still a lot
for him to live up to because he's been
that prodigy for so long just couldn't
compete because he was too young and now
he's finally here and he had his first
failure but a roster change turned
things around for vitality so we're
already gonna try with different people
who were trying of different players and
then k-dog he was like who wants to join
us right so we're like well of course of
course cuz that man I think at that time
he'd won two World Championships already
and he just came to the grand finals of
course you're gonna take him you know
and as soon as we started playing
instantly it really started to click
like things really start to pop off
[Applause]
[Music]
energy in this
[Music]
he and Kate
[Music]
this gene should dominate and guess what
that is exactly what they did
the turnaround was a huge confidence
booster sure but it also proved that
scrub Killa was still worth taking
seriously and he had his eyes on the
biggest prize the world championship
going into Worlds is obviously gonna be
a hell of a bigger energy Mac you know
not to put that remark of course but as
the world's the world championship you
know that isn't it it's just everything
vitality we're ready to take on the
world
and their determination paid off still
the control in their favor an
opportunity struck killer looking to
equalize the drop down the Kate off it's
past two up two fire fighters
[Applause]
was it dormant alpha squishing one last
chance
[Applause]
that long
vitality takes game 1 vitality the new
territory that got into the box
[Applause]
downfield charity midfield he's under
one
scrub touch over Chicago
such as what
carried I'll take that one away Jay now
have to flip around try to make a save
and now it's
around the corner spoke killer Hospital
[Applause]
vitality stood on top of the world
triumphant and scrub killa earned an MVP
title for his outstanding performance
scrub killa proved himself on the world
stage he wasn't some washed-up
up-and-comer he was the best player in
the world and the youngest world
champion ever I felt confident going
into LAN going in AD a CFL called for
them you know it was a really great team
atmosphere it was a great season you
know and when I know what championship
is a great great feeling so but scrub
wasn't done finally achieving his dream
of winning Worlds was only the first
step he wanted to do it again I always
feel like I got more to prove that's why
my favorite things is just like prove
people wrong you know they say you know
you can't do this you can't do that and
then you do it I've got what it takes to
win again you know I'm just gonna have
to work really hard and after qualifying
for the season eight world finals
vitality made it all the way back to the
grand finals where they were just one
goal away from me coming back to back
champions
[Applause]
great play to this corner very pink he's
got faster plays looks rough
[Applause]
but as disappointing as the loss was it
was just another step in scrub killers
journey so vitally and my contract ended
for the start of this year so now I'm
not part of them because both my
teammates quite have a full French team
so they can come and only French which
would you know I think that's fair
and so I'm a free agent but I've got a
team to go through of course I can can't
really say that and you just have to
wait and see whatever happens down the
road
scrub Kela has already achieved his
first goal of playing in worlds and
winning whoever signs him next they're
not getting some promising young star
they're getting a battle-scarred veteran
who's hungry for a second title but
supersonic acrobatic rocket powered
battle cars was only a pit stop on
Scrubs journey how can I say that whole
thing but sometimes I [ __ ] up saying the
word cat this is why this is why it
didn't do as well as a rocket League and
came with a really easy to remember
title they got it when they made the
sequel it's also feels like I'm doing
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious right
like